La invasión rusa de Ucrania no solo está
cambiando radicalmente la geopolítica, la
seguridad y la forma de ver el mundo de Europa,
también está suponiendo enormes cambios
para Rusia…
Y a medida que pase el tiempo esto se irá
notando más y más.
En un reciente vídeo (meter thumbnail) aquí
en VisualPolitik ya os contamos como las sanciones
a Rusia están logrando muchos de los objetivos
que se habían fijado.
(Rusia es, en términos cuantitativos, el
país más sancionado de todo el mundo.
Concretamente, el 2023 arrancó con 13.600
sanciones y restricciones de todo tipo sobre
el estado ruso, las empresas del país o muchos
oligarcas cercanos al Kremlin.
De todas ellas casi 11.000 fueron impuestas
tras la invasión de Ucrania el día 24 de
febrero del 2022.
Para que os hagáis y podáis comparar, sobre
Irán, el segundo país más sancionado del
mundo, pesan poco más de 4.000 sanciones
y restricciones, y sobre Siria y Corea del
Norte, unas 2.600 y 2.100 respectivamente.)
Y eso no es todo.
Las economías occideantales y en general
la mayor parte de los aliados de Ucrania han
hecho esfuerzos titánicos para librarse progresivamente
de todo aquello que proceda de Rusia: su gas,
su petróleo, el dinero de los oligarcas…
Todo, excepto, una cosa: los suministros del
sector nuclear ruso.
Hablamos concretamente de Rosatom, un enorme
grupo industrial propiedad del gobierno ruso
que, por ahora, ha escapado de las sanciones.
Ha quedado libre por un motivo:
hoy por hoy lo que ofrece esta empresa es
mucho más difícil de reemplazar que los
hidrocarburos.
Así que a pesar de los enormes esfuerzos
que ha hecho Zelenskiy presionando a sus aliados
para que también sancionen a Rosatom, hasta
ahora no lo ha conseguido.
(9 de enero de 2023: Ucrania espera que la
UE incluya a la rusa Rosatom en las próximas
sanciones - Reuters)
Y ojo, que hablamos, ni más ni menos, que
de la empresa estatal rusa de energía atómica.
Y eso no es todo.
Este gigante del sector nuclear es virtualmente
la única empresa rusa que podemos decir que
realmente está a la altura de las mejores
del mundo en su sector, ya sea por tecnología,
competitividad, costes o calidad.
Es algo así como la gran excepción del tejido
industrial ruso, un entorno productivo que,
¿que quereis que os diga?
Se caracteriza por su ineficiencia, su corrupción
ddesmedida y un profundo desfase tecnológico
respecto a sus contrapartes occidentales.
Pero eso con esta empresa no es así, más
bien todo lo contrario.
[Claro, a ver, que la industria nuclear occidental
haya sido vapuleada por las políticas anti
nucleares de las últimas décadas pues, lógicamente,
ha contribuido a que Rosatom gane cuota de
mercado.]
Ahora bien…
¿Qué es realmente Rosatom?
¿A qué se dedican concretamente?
¿Por qué no se han impuesto sanciones sobre
esta empresa?
¿Puede esto cambiar?
Es decir, ¿Hay motivos para sancionar al
gigante nuclear ruso?
¿Qué papel juega esta compañía en el entramado
político, económico y militar de la Rusia
de Vladimir Putin?
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas y algunas más.
Arranquemos.
T1(LA HIJA MIMADA DE PUTIN)
Como seguramente la mayor parte de vosotros
ya sabéis, la caída de la Unión Soviética
vino seguida de un periodo de varios años
de profunda crisis dónde se registró una
enorme debacle económica y también industrial.
Y obviamente el sector nuclear no fue una
excepción…
A pesar de que la Unión Soviética fue una
enorme potencia en energía nuclear civil.
Por ejemplo, fue la URSS donde nació la primera
central nuclear del mundo que introdujo electricidad
a la red.
Lo hizo en 1954.
La central de Obninsk, con apenas 5 MW de
potencia, hizo historia, pero ese solo iba
a ser el principio de un largo camino.
Desde entonces, los soviéticos diseñaron
o construyeron más de 60 reactores nucleares
distribuidos por todo el país y por el resto
del bloque comunista formado por un sinfin
de países satélites.
Consiguieron así un importante know how y
una buena reputación, al menos hasta el accidente
nuclear de Chernobyl en 1986.
Pues bien, el caso es que cuando cayó la
URSS también cayó todo el tejido industrial
del estado.
Algunas de estas industrias tradicionales
nunca llegaron a recuperarse, otras lo hicieron
pero a un nivel mucho peor que su competencia
occidental, y otras, en cambio, fueron reflotadas
con mimo por parte del gobierno.
Este último caso fue precisamente el de Rosatom.
(El propio Vladimir Putin se tomó como un
asunto personal y prioritario reflotar la
industria nuclear.
Para ello en 2006 promulgó una Ley que buscaba
crear todo un marco estratégico a largo plazo
para el sector nuclear, y poco después en
2007 el propio Putin fundó Rosatom como una
corporación estatal.
Detrás de esta decisión estuvo la preocupación
del gobierno ruso por la creciente brecha
entre la demanda y el suministro de electricidad.
Es decir, que con Rosatom pretendían solucionar
de una vez por todas la escasez lectricas
y evitar así que siguiese perjudicando a
la economía.
Además, durante la década de los 90, al
no tener un productor de referencia, Rusia
se había quedado fuera del mercado internacional
de la energía nuclear.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre principios
de los 90 y mediados de los años 2000, en
el mundo se construyeron más de 100 reactores
nucleares en cuya construcción y diseño
Rusia no pudo participar.
Es decir que en Moscú comprendieron que se
estaban perdiendo un gran negocio.)
Así que dicho y hecho.
Rosatom nació con un brutal impulso financiero
por parte del Estado ruso y con el propio
Vladimir Putin involucrado al cien por cien
en esta misión.
De hecho, es él mismo el que decide quién
dirige esta empresa y quien hace los nombramientos
más relevantes.
El caso es que con esta compañía la energía
nuclear rusa ha vuelto a abrirse paso y día
de hoy es ya uno de los mayores actores internacionales
en el sector de la energía nuclear.
Pero, para ser más claros, me basta con daros
un solo dato: de los 53 reactores nucleares
que estaban en construcción en todo el mundo
a mediados de 2022, 20 estaban siendo construidos
por Rosatom, y de ellos 17 estaban fuera de
Rusia.
Es decir, hablamos de una cuota de mercado
de casi el 40%.
Y, ojo, porque Francia y Corea del Sur están
también construyendo reactores fuera de sus
respectivas fronteras, pero apenas participan
en un par de proyectos cada uno.
Pero ahí no termina todo.
La empresa rusa también se encarga en muchos
casos del mantenimiento y la supervisión
de los reactores nucleares de tecnología
rusa que hay repartidos por todo el mundo.
Hablamos de aproximaaamente el 20 por ciento
de los casi 450 reactores en operaciones que
podemos encontrar.
En otras palabras, que podemos decir sin temor
a equivocarnos que Rosatom en sus poco más
de 15 años de vida ha logrado dominar el
mercado nuclear internacional.
Al menos convertirse en el actor más importante.
(”Los rusos son hipercompetitivos, nadie
en la Organización para la Cooperación y
el Desarrollo Económico [OCDE] puede competir
con lo que ofrecen.”
- Marc-Antoine Eyl-Mazzega, director del centro
de energía y clima del Instituto Francés
de Relaciones Internacionales)
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues todavía, esperad, hay mucho más.
solo acamos de empezar.
Al final, si lo pensáis un momento, el motivo
por el que Occidente no ha sancionado a Rosatom
no puede ser solo sus exportaciones de reactores
nucleares.
Al fin y al cabo, Estados Unidos no tiene
ni se plantea tener reactores nucleares rusos,
y en Europa la energía nuclear lleva años
marginada y ahora, que está resurgiendo,
se está optando mayoritariamente por proveedores
de tecnología nuclear occidentales o surcoreanos.
Entonces, ¿por qué diantres no se sanciona
de una vez a Rosatom?
¿Qué hay en juego para que esta posibilidad
por ahora haya sido descartada¿
Pues bien, aquí llega quizás la parte más
interesante de toda esta historia.
Prestad mucha atención.
T2(ÁTOMOS MADE IN RUSSIA)
Las sanciones al gas y al petróleo ruso se
impusieron de forma relativamente rápida,
muy Sin embargo, en el momento en el que preparamos
este vídeo Rosatom ha conseguido librarse
de cualquier castigo o restricción.
Y esto, obviamente, tiene que tener una explicación.
Que obviamente la tiene: esta empresa no solo
se dedica al diseño y la construcción de
reactores nucleares, sino que también enriquece
uranio.
(A pesar de que aquí sí que podemos encontrar
importantes proveedores occidentales, Rosatom
es el mayor productor mundial de uranio enriquecido,
con cerca del 30 por ciento de la producción
y casi la mitad de toda la capacidad mundial.
Además, controla el 17 por ciento del mercado
global de combustible para reactores nucleares.
Y según la propia empresa, 73 reactores nucleares
en 13 países diferentes funionan gracias
a su combustible.
Y no hablamos solo de las viejas centrales
de origen soviético.
En 2021, por ejemplo, Rosatom proporcionó
casi una cuarta parte de todo el combustible
nuclear usado por las centrales nucleares
de Estados Unidos.
Además, se estima que incluso en un escenario
de cambio de proveedores los rusos retendrán
al menos un 15 por ciento del pastel en Estados
Unidos a corto y medio plazo.
Esto es debido a que resulta un proceso muy
lento y costoso especializarse en la producción
de combustible nuclear a escala y precios
razonables.)
Evidentemente su cuota de mercado en Europa
no es menor.
Los rusos proporcionan en torno al 20 por
ciento de todo el uranio que importa la Unión
Europea, tan solo por detrás de Níger y
Kazajistán, así como el 26% del uranio enriquecido.
De hecho, de vez en cuando se pueden ver por
los cielos europeos aviones de carga rusos
volando a países como Hungría o Eslovaquia
con combustible nuclear, gracias a precisamente
a las excepciones que se introdujeron a la
prohibición de entrada de aviones rusos.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué es todo esto resulta
tan importante?
¿Hablamos realmente de algo tan imprescindible
como para dejar a Rosatom fuera de las sanciones
occidentales?
Pues… lo cierto es que sí, y puede que
no sea exactamente por lo que estéis pensando.
Veámoslo.
T3(LA INFLUENCIA ESTRATÉGICA)
Rosatom es una empresa enorme con un gran
portfolio de contratos en el sector nuclear.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2021 reportó
unos beneficios récord de 20.000 millones
de dólares.
Y no solo eso, el holding Atomenergoprom,
en el que se unifica gran parte de la actividad
de Rosatom, tenía ese mismo año un portfolio
de pedidos en el extranjero de cerca de 140.000
millones de dólares a ejecutar durante la
próxima década.
Y sí, algunos de los contratos de construcción
de reactores nucleares que engrosan toda esa
enorme cantidad de proyectos están en países
de la OTAN, algunos, incluso, supuestos aliados
de Ucrania.
Fijaos.
(27 de agosto de 2022: Hungría avanza en
la construcción de reactores nucleares de
fabricación rusa
A pesar de la guerra de Moscú en Ucrania,
las obras en la planta de Paks comenzarán
en las "próximas semanas", dijo el ministro
de Relaciones Exteriores de Hungría - Politico)
(30 de julio de 2022: La rusa Rosatom firma
un nuevo contrato de construcción para una
central nuclear turca
El gobierno turco tiene como objetivo comenzar
a operar el primer reactor de la planta, que
tendrá un total de 4.800 megavatios (MW),
antes de las elecciones generales del próximo
año.
El presidente Tayyip Erdogan sugirió anteriormente
que Turquía podría trabajar con Rusia en
la construcción de dos plantas más.)
Pues bien, la construcción de reactores y
su mantenimiento es con diferencia el negocio
más lucrativo para Rosatom.
De hecho, os vamos a dar otro dato.
Las importaciones anuales de uranio y combustible
nuclear desde Rusia realizadas por Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea son imprescindibles
pero suponen apenas 1.000 millones de dólares
al año.
Que sí, es mucho dinero, pero no tiene nada
que ver con los cerca de 200.000 millones
que se importaban de Rusia en hidrocarburos
justo antes de la guerra.
Y tampoco tienen nada que ver con lo que ingresa
Rosatom con su negocio de reactores y centrales.
Entonces, con todo esto, puede que os estéis
preguntando… ¿y no se podría sancionar
a Rosatom para evitar que pueda construir
nuevos reactores y centrales, pero seguirles
comprando el uranio y el combustible nuclear
hasta que se pu eda sustituir totalmente?
Pues sí, lo cierto es que sí, y eso sería
probablemente lo que más daño les haría.
Pero hay dos inconvenientes.
(Por un lado, dar este paso en un mercado
tan restringido y con pocos proveedores como
este podría hacer que la propia Rusia estuviera
dispuesta a sacrificar esos ingresos para
dejar a Occidente sin su combustible nuclear.
Y esto, en Estados Unidos y Europa podría
causar verdaderos problemas de abastecimiento
para las centrales en un momento de elevados
precios de los hidrocarburos.)
Y luego hay otro problema, y es que no hay
tantos proveedores de tecnología nuclear
para centrales modernas.
Es decir, prohibir importar esas tecnologías
probablemente generaría un cuello de botella
de pedidos a la industria nuclear civil de
países como Estados Unidos, Francia o Corea
del Sur que amenazaría el suministro energético
mundial.
Y lo haría precisamente en el que se espera
que sea el mayor periodo de electrificación
de la historia de la humanidad debido al cumplimiento
de objetivos climáticos, algo de lo que por
cierto, ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
Así que la realidad es que, les guste o no,
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea deberán
ser muy cautos a la hora de imponer sanciones
contra Rosatom, y ese es precisamente el motivo
por el que hasta ahora esta empresa ha salido
indemne.
Ahora bien, ¿es esto irreversible?
Pues no, por supuesto que no.
De hecho tanto Estados Unidos como la Unión
Europea tienen ya planes para impulsar su
producción de uranio enriquecido y combustible
para centrales.
(Estados Unidos redobla esfuerzos para poner
fin a la dependencia del combustible nuclear
ruso
La Casa Blanca está priorizando el desarrollo
de capacidad nacional de enriquecimiento de
uranio, y predijo que los legisladores clave
se alinearán, de modo que el plan de fabricación
de combustible pueda estar en marcha para
2025 - Bloomberg)
(Las nucleares incluidas en el plan REPowerEU
de la UE
La Comisión Europea ha adoptado formalmente
el plan REPowerEU, cuyo objetivo es reducir
rápidamente la dependencia de la UE de los
combustibles fósiles rusos.
El plan [...] destaca la importancia de una
acción coordinada para reducir la dependencia
de los materiales y del ciclos del combustible
nuclear rusos.
- World Nuclear News)
Pero claro, hasta que todo eso se materialice,
Rosatom seguirá teniendo una importancia
clave para su suministro.
El riesgo que se corre ahora es que la dependencia
de occidente permita a esta empresa convertirse
en una especie de by-pass para las sanciones
y desviar tecnologías, compras de suministros
y sus beneficios financiar la campaña militar.
(Por lo pronto, Rosatom ya ha participado
activamente en la invasión a Ucrania, ya
que es el actual operador de la central nuclear
de Zaporizhzhia y también su propietario
de facto mientras esta permanezca ocupada.
Además la empresa actúa de acuerdo a las
órdenes del gobierno ruso a la hora de operar
esta central ucraniana, que es la más grande
de Europa con un total de seis reactores.
Desde el principio de la ocupación de la
central, se han estado conectando y desconectando
unidades a capricho del Kremlin para minar
la moral de los ucranianos y evitar que obtengan
dinero exportando electricidad a sus vecinos
europeos.)
De hecho, este es uno de los grandes argumentos
que el gobierno ucraniano esgrime para pedir
que se sancione lo antes posible a esta empresa
pero, como habéis visto, incluso a pesar
de su colaboración en la guerra, las cosas
no resultan nada fáciles.
En definitiva, Rosatom más que como un enorme
balón financiero para el Kremlin - que también
lo es - funciona como una baza de presión
estratégica a nivel político.
Como una línea roja en la que, desgraciadamente,
Rusia tiene ventaja.
Pero ahora, llegados a este punto, el turno
es para ti.
¿Crees que Estados Unidos y Europa harían
bien poniendo en riesgo su producción de
energía nuclear para sancionar a Rosatom?
¿Puede ser esta empresa la última gran baza
estratégica de Putin fuera del terreno de
batalla?
Pues bien, déjanos tus opiniones aquí debajo,
en los comentarios.
Y recuerda, si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Y recuerda, puedes ayudarnos a crecer y a
mejorar sumándose a nuestra comunidad en
Patreon.
Os dejamos el enlace aquí debajo.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.